So Dark Souls 3 has added a bunch of new
refinements that are really good for the
game but of course they're also really
hidden and you shouldn't have to puzzle
them out yourself like I did. Let me
tell you about them
number one is that you can hold down on
the D pad and you'll be brought to the
first item in your quick select bar. For
most people this will be their healing
estus flask and I recommend you keep it that
way because, man, once you discover this
mechanic you'll no longer be like "Ah where
the fuck is my estus" and die while
you're toggling for it. It's great
there's no longer a drawback to having
ten items in your quick select bar.
For number two everyone knows that fashion
Souls is far more important than the
worthless stats on your armor. For
example, these gloves have far better
defense, poise and resistances but they
show my skinny hollow elbows and that
just won't do so now the game helps you
curate the perfect fashion all with the
press of the right analog stick at the
equipment screen. That's better. And at
some point in your journey you gonna
take off that helmet and be like "holy
shit I look like beef jerky". Well don't worry.
In Dark Souls 3 it's almost a
good thing to go hollow, so let me explain.
When you rescued a character called
Yoel on the Undead Settlement bridge, you
can bring him back to your shrine and
when you talk to him there, you have the
option to "draw out your true strength". Selecting this option lets you level
up once for free, but there is a hidden
catch. When you level up for free at Yoel,
you receive a Dark Sigil in the key slot of your inventory and every time you
die with a Dark Sigil in your inventory,
you receive a point of hollowing in your
Stat screen, visible here. The more
hollowing you get, the more you look like
beef jerky, the darker your covenant
symbol becomes and the more excited
Yoel gets. Every few points of hollowing
just check back at Yoel and he'll let
you level up again getting you another
Dark Sigil in your inventory, giving you more
points of hollowing when you die and
again and again until you level up five
times at Yoel and he dies of
excitement. In his place
Yuria appears and
the hollowing quest line continues. I
highly highly recommend that you go down
this quest line because in my opinion
it's one of the best ones in the game
however it is very very tricky to do
right so check out my lore through series
if you're interested in doing the quest
line we're gonna go through it there.
If you spent hours curating the perfect waifu -I
wouldn't do that but some people like to
do it it's weird- anyway don't worry it's
easy to reverse hollowing: just buy a
purging stone from Yuria and you can
remove all the hollowing points and
furthermore if you give a fire keeper
soul to the fire keeper then she'll heal the
dark sigils in your inventory so you
won't hollow again. Good looks don't come
cheap though so remember that. Number
four is that it's now way easier to play
with your mates: just set a password
shared between you both and all of a
sudden you will be able to be summoned
regardless of your soul level. To balance
this the game will scale down the Phantoms
strength to match the hosts. Also you
can't drop a weapon for your friend that
exceeds his or her maximum upgraded
weapon. How cool is this summoning
system though. For so long we've been
leveling up characters alongside our
friends and that gets so tricky and
complicated. This simplifies things so
much. But I'll tell you what I like more
than friends:
invading people. Once you get the red eye
orb from Ringfinger Leonhard, you can use
it to invade indefinitely. I'll
explain his quest line in another video,
but did you know that the rewards you
get for killing a host now depend on
which covenant you're in? For example if I
invade with the red eye orb and a sunbro
medal equipped, then I'll get sun
light medals for killing. If you go in as
a red phantom mound maker I'll get a
vertebra shackle for killing, and so on
if I invade as anything else I think
though I get a pale tongue, which is a
reward for the fingers of Rosaria
covenant, which is associated with the
red eye orb. So if you want to farm those
three covenant rewards, then PvP with a
friend or invade others, it's really
good for switching it up.
additionally the color of your red
phantom now changes depending on your
equipped covenant as well.
You can see here I'm this sexy golden red
phantom because I'm a sunbro invader
I love the way it looks. so yeah try some jolly murdering
for once. Another related thing is to do
with invasion requirements: you can only
invade people who match or are below
your maximum upgraded weapon leve,l in
addition to the soul level system also
being in place. A user named Prinex
on Reddit actually did a great write-up on
invasion requirements and you should go
and check it out, it's really interesting.
I'll put it in the description below. Number
six: one thing that I discovered from
watching PvP streamers was that you can
now parry people even if they attack you
from behind.
Apparently a shield parry now affects
phantoms in a 360 radius around you. But
is this a bug or feature? Time will tell.
For number seven I've written down that
you can perform visceral attacks on a ton of
enemies, some of whom don't even look
staggerable. The head is what you often
want to aim for on many enemy creatures,
but the main thing I wanna talk about is
that if you hit an enemy regularly
during this time, just with a light attack
for example, you will now hear a different
sound which indicates that you're
dealing more damage during their
vulnerable state.
You also hear this sound on counter hits
and all the other vulnerable times, it's
a nice touch.
Number eight: when you run and press R2 now you do a jumping attack. These can also be
initiated by pressing forward and R2 of course. What's also new is that you
can do a rolling attack animation
immediately after the jumping attack. I
found for most weapons this is really
good for Crystal lizards because jumping
attacks often fling them onto their back
and rolling attacks are often vertical
or pokes. Number nine: when you do a
jump by pressing L3 when you're
running, you no longer have to do the
mandatory roll at the end of it. If you
stop pressing forward on the left analog
stick as soon as you initiate the jump,
then your character will come to a
standstill, like this. This is
particularly good for tricky jumping
puzzles like this one, but there really
aren't many uses for this right now at
all, which is a shame. I never thought
Dark Souls needed jumping puzzles because
the jumping mechanic has always been
trash, but the fact that this exists,
that you don't have to roll is almost
like an Easter egg. It would be interesting
if they put a puzzle where you have to
stop the jump, you can't do the roll in
order to get the reward. I think that
would be neat. Alright number ten: using weapon arts with no focus still works for
a lot of weapons and while their
effectiveness is often reduced, some
weapons are worth using simply for their
weapon art. For example the sunlight
straight sword has a buff that you can
apply even with tiny bit of focus and
daggers have a quick step that functions
with no focus at all. This is
particularly handy when you're rolling
through the swamp: just equip a dagger and fly
through the swamp with the weapon art
instead. Look at how much faster this is.
It brought my swamp experience up to a
almost bearable,
it's pretty good. The next five secrets are
little quickfire secrets. First, you can
do a charge attack by holding R2 like in
Bloodborne. You can also throw some
knives while running and some spells
like Farron Dart while running as well
you get a heavy roll at above 70%
equip burden so it's very beneficial
to stay below 70 percent. Power stance
dual wielding no longer exists in Dark
Souls 3 which is sad, because I think
that was one of the best things that
Dark Souls 2 brought to the table. You
can now two-hand dual wieldable weapons
instead. And for number fifteen I want
you to go and check out this video. It's
by a streamer named Scott Jund who did an
awesome little write-up on how defense works
in Dark Souls 3. My favorite discovery in that
video was that having an empty armor slot
is something you just never want to do,
and that even wearing rags in that armor slot
can drastically increase your defense. So
subscribe if you want to. This channel is
all about Dark Souls so we got stories and
tips and guides, and if you have any
other tips, throw them in the comments
section. It's really fun to be able to
unpack the game with you guys and I'm
sure there's some stuff I've missed and
I hope there is, because I don't want
this to end.
Also if you have another browser tab
free, open up rbfrosty's
twitch stream and throw him a follow, because
he helped a ton with all the
multiplayer testing, and he is another
great streamer in the community that you
should support. Thanks for watching and
supporting me and I'll see you in the next one
for more Dark Souls 3.